[Music]
it's very important that we have this
department now at this current time
[Music]
because our nation needs the kinds of
knowledge that this department produces
and will continue to produce Columbia
has a long-standing tradition of what we
could call now african-american studies
in Black Studies you know going back to
the days of Franz boas but even in
particular after 1968 you see ourselves
as a Harlem institution I mean African
American Studies at Columbia joins the
Schomburg and Harlem stage and the
Studio Museum and all of those like
August Harlem institutions of
intellectuals from the United States of
the Caribbean and Africa all of whom are
committed to the very best scholarly
work we now join them as a full-fledged
department at the University